we had broccolis got some Dino kale here
we have a tomato plants a variety of
different types of lettuces two years
ago Ken Armstrong started a different
kind of vegetable patches in pescadero
California people asked me if I was
doing farming before this and I told him
no in fact everything I ever tried to
grow I killed because i forgot the water
and you can see the root systems nice
clean white roots and that is one
beautiful head ellipse or Boris farm is
an aquaponics farm where fish and
produce grow together in a symbiotic
relationship all the nutrients are
available to the plants at all times
they expend less energy putting out root
systems you can expend more energy in
the growth here's how it works in this
pond there are 800 catfish being raised
on organic fish feed Heights then carry
fish waste water to crops where plants
grow on floating rafts their roots
dangle on the water below sucking up the
nitrogen rich fertilizer the plants have
taken out those nitrates and used all
those nutrients out of the system the
clean water then gets returned the fish
tank we're gets renew TRO fight and then
begins the whole process again
aquaponics is basically a combination of
plant farm and fish farm combining the
two cancels out the negatives of both he
coli and Salmonella require a
warm-blooded animal in order for those
microbes to propagate fish are
cold-blooded so in an aquaponic system
is not possible to have either a coli or
salmonella another advantage with
aquaponics to as most fish can then be
harvested out and used as a protein
source aquaponic farms are expensive to
construct but once built they're
actually less expensive to run than
land-based farms the self-contained
ponds eliminate the need for fertilizers
pesticides or pricey farm equipment and
though it may seem counterintuitive to
grow vegetables in giant pools of water
during one of the worst droughts in
history aquaponic farms use ninety
percent less water than conventional
farming
because the water is continuously
recycled and it's not lost in the soil
or to evaporation they could restrict
our water usage by eighty percent and it
wouldn't affect us at all turns out
aquaponic farming is older than dirt the
Chinese used carp in their rice paddies
and now this ancient farming method
majors proved to be the modern solution
to drought I honestly believe this is
the evolution of farming that aquaponics
because of its ability to grow faster
more densely with fewer resources that
it will be a methodology of growing in
the future